Hey guys just kind of like a massive major workout my thighs are pumped my thighs are pumped my everything's pumped up so big I can't even like I don't know I pass a mirror and I'm like wait a minute where did Sean go and it's he's right here so but who am I kidding I didn't work out I never work out I woke up this morning about the NASA thing they've seen this read this thing that the Voyager you know it's like 15 billion miles away yeah they don't quite know what's there's something going on with it where they're not receiving correct information but they're still receiving information and I'm interested in that shit did I just
lose everybody no yeah you don't you want to try to stay away from just half stories okay yeah I was gonna say I was gonna say like I'd be interested if you gave me actually anything interesting to think about okay well I can tell you what happened with my I got my MRI back for my neck this I want to know about okay okay and would they say it's a I got a better story okay so listen so this is a true story as you can notice I got my haircut yesterday right it's really really short and I got a little color in there to so Oh, Skevo, blah, blah, blah, joke, joke, joke.
Skevo, Greek, fantastic. Oh, hang on. Ba-da-ba-ba-ba-da-da-da, ba-da-ba-ba-da-ba. Is that what we do now to fucking, the fuck is going on? What are we, at a kid's birthday party? So I'm sitting there. Wait, wait, wait, you just glossed over the rinse.
You put a rinse in there, huh? What was the, what's the name of the color on that rinse? It's usually something like chestnut forever or something like that. No, that's my handle on my profile and my... On your weight is, no, it's... It's two words, chestnuts. No, it's nut on chest, right?
Please nut on chest. Dot com. Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da, ba-da-da-da-da-da-da, ba-da-da-da-da-da-da, ba-da-da-da-da-da-da. We really got to get a snare drum in here. Oh, I got that, I got that swissle. Oh boy, here it comes. Here it comes, Sheki, go, Sheki.
So, listen. So wait, so I'm sitting there and you know Chris McMillan who does your hair, Jason. Sure. I'm sitting on the other side in his station across and I go, Chris, get me something like a piece of candy or something. I want some sugar or some sweet.
And he goes back and he's like, I don't have anything. You want me to make you a peanut butter sandwich? I was like, no, I don't want that. So I'm sitting there and Skevo's got my hair. And like 10 minutes later, he hands me a bag of chocolates. He sent somebody out to get me chocolate. It's full service over there. Isn't that the nicest thing in the world?
Chris did or Skevo did? Chris did. That's pretty nice. The guy who owns the salon. That's pretty nice. I know Chris. I know for Tracy. I can't believe you're asking them for snacks in there.
Why don't you just go in there and behave yourself? There wasn't a please in there. You were like, hey, Skevo, give me some candy. You said, hey, Chris, give me some candy. I know. What is going on? You're a tyrant. You're so sweet.
I can't believe that. That he actually sent somebody out to get me chocolate. Also, who eats peanut butter in a hair salon? The hair is going to get stuck in it gross. That sounds disgusting to me. Well, anyway, listen, I don't want to keep our guest waiting. I do. Okay, listen, so with all this momentum,
the hilarious momentum, let's go ahead and intro the guest. I'm super excited about her. Don't make me do it again. I'm super excited. I was just at arm's length. That is what's so weird. That little slide was like, I'd have to drive 10 miles
to buy one of those. And yours is just arm's length. I don't even know what the search terms are for it. All right, good. I'm super excited about our sweet, kind, funny, cutest pie guest today. I had the pleasure of standing next to her as we both voiced characters in that animated show
I did last year, Q-Force. And she made me laugh really hard. She's the epitome of a workaholic. She doesn't stop working. And I'm not sure why she's on smart list because she graduated valedictorian of her class from Milton Academy before attending Columbia as a lit major.
She started in films like Obvious Child and Gifted. She's guest starred on Parks and Recs and Girls and everything funny you can think of. Earlier this year, she starred with our friend, Charlie Day in the Amazon original rom-com. I want you back. And she is, of course, the star of my favorite animated character of all time, Marcel.
The shell with shoes on. It's a wonderfully talented and hysterical Jenny Slate. Jenny Slate. Who's really great. Jenny Slate. Hi, Jenny. Jenny, thanks for being here. This is so cool.
Oh my gosh, it's so, I don't know if your guests say this a lot, but like the energy mounting waiting to be revealed. And then I'll like, it depends on what your personality is. But if you're like, oh my gosh, what if I'm like a bad surprise and no one cares or, and then you guys are so funny. And I was laughing and I didn't trust the mute. I was like, maybe, like maybe I'll laugh so hard. I'll bust through the mute.
As the youngest of five children, I'm a bad surprise. So. Oh, here it is. Oh, don't show it. My name, my name, my name, my name, my name, my name, my name. You know what, Jenny? I'm so sorry. First of all, hi.
Nice to meet you. Hi. You've never met. You get to do the Lego Batman movie together. Oh, wait. We've met briefly. Yeah, but we didn't record. I think we briefly in passing, but this is our first conversation.
We've never had an actual dialogue. So, yeah. Oh, wow. Double snub before double snub. What about no chatting at the craft service table? Did you guys not? They didn't have one. Sean, tell Tracy what a craft service table is.
Craft service is where they feed the cast off the side, like with a line of just food on tables. It's a snack table. It's a snack table for everybody. More easily said. Yeah. I read somewhere, Jenny, that you are like, because I'm looking at where you are right now that you're like.
I'm not in my home. That's what I was going to say. OK, so that's what I was going to say. Listener, it looks like she's in a supply closet. She's running a travel agent to see what's going on. Yeah? I'm in a supply closet. OK, look, I'm in a supply closet that.
It looks like you got last night's dress hanging on a hook behind you, too. There's a toilet underneath me. There's a toilet. So here it is. That's where you want it to be. Are you on a boat? Are you in the head on a boat?
Or are you just suffering from colitis right now, and you just want to stay ready? You know, I don't feel safe. I don't feel like myself, unless there's a toilet truly screwed in with what's full on plumbing into just whatever space I'm in. And I need that, but even for podcast. Directly under you.
Yeah, so I live, for most of the year, in a small town in Massachusetts by the ocean. And I live on a little peninsula. And we have Wi-Fi that is like internet that my mother-in-law put in there in the late 90s, I want to say. And no one has ever decided to improve upon it. And so when it's raining, literally, it's like raining
today, there's not even really a breath of wind. But the internet becomes very bad. And so my husband owns the general store. So I came up here with my computer and my like power cord trailing, like a little tail. And was like, can I use it? Jenny, this is crazy. Can you, I know there's not a breath of wind.
What's the five-day outlook? I'm going to tell you what, Bill, we're going to get into the high 70s is what I heard. Now, Jenny, this sounds like an ideal life you live. Tell us slow about this peninsula. And what did you say most of the year at the general store? Does he wear an apron? Here's the thing, in ideal life, still
have the same personality that I had in LA. So I'm waiting for the adjustment to kick in for that chillness, that chillness to get. Maybe you need to move to chill, Mark. Come on. You come, hang on a second. Sean? Brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr.
So we're about keeping your safety in mind so you don't need to get too specific. Whereabouts are you in Massachusetts? Sure. I can see Martha's Vineyard from where I live. Are you in Woods Hole? I'm not in Woods Hole. I'm in what they call South Coast, Massachusetts.
And I'm from Massachusetts, and I did not know that this area existed. And my husband and I were kind of, oh yeah. Where are you from? Where are you from, Jenny? I'm from Milton, Mass. No shit, huh? Matter of fact, I used to know a kid.
No, he's from fucking, he's from Bill Ricker, but I knew this other kid from Milton. Fucking good kid. You should see this dude. What's his name? His name's Sully, obviously. Oh yeah, everyone is. But he's from Bill Ricker, but he lives in Milton
and he works in Peabody. That's where my cousins live. They live in Peabody. Me and fucking Peabody? I'm not kidding. I'm not kidding. Do they work for the Edison? What's that, like the Edison, like the, like, Con Edison?
Yeah, the fucking power company. Yeah, it is. Yeah, you know. Like, Con Edison. Jenny Slate, how did you, so did you just stumble into this general store one day and you said, hey, handsome felon and apron? No, ding ding ding and the bells went
when she opened the door. I don't see a ring on that finger. What about we get a malt? Yeah, yeah, listen, it's not, it's not how it went. I wish that that would be really nice. That's so romantic. But in fact, I met my husband in. Online?
Well, in the Arctic. In the Arctic. Oh, really? In the Arctic. I met him in Arctic Norway. It's coming. What? I know.
It's like, it all just sounds like, you know, those people who try to have stuff to make them more interesting, but they're actually like basic. So they say stuff like this. This is a great pitch. This is a great pitch. Keep going.
So you guys meet in the Arctic, uh-huh. So she's in the Arctic. Yeah, she's in the Arctic. She's an artist. She's in the Arctic. She's there for art. But what she does find is love. By the end, you realize that love is art and art is love.
And she's standing on the end of a peninsula with a toilet underneath her. Yeah. Can I just say that we love this? We'd like to take this off the table. The kind of thing we're looking at. We'd like to take this off the table now. It's truly first time I've ever sold anything in the room.
Wait, wait, so you met in the, how did you meet in the Arctic? What were you doing in Arctic Norway? I was making a movie there. And my friend wrote the movie and her now husband is best friends with my now husband. And so they, and I was there and they invited him to come there
and like hang out with us. To Norway. Was it a setup or just a visit? Well, this, it was just a visit. I guess there wasn't a lot of pressure put on it. So you didn't know it was a possible setup. Did he know it was a possible setup? He must have to like pack your bags
and fly all the way. For what? There's this great girl here. He must have had some sort of carrot there, right? Did he know? Well, he, he lived in Amsterdam. So we didn't go that far. You know, it's not like he came from Massachusetts.
That would be like, totally. Is he from Amsterdam? No, he's from Massachusetts, but he was living in Amsterdam. No, he's originally from Mass too. What town is he from too? Oh, let's revisit this joke. We live in his childhood home. Oh, right.
Sorry, I forgot. No, no, no, it's Will's fault. It's Will's fault. No, I should let him run his course. Yeah. No. You know what? You know what, Bateman?
Fuck you. Shut the fuck up, Bateman. Oh my God. Jenny, you, the reason why I asked about your, where you're sitting right now, cause it does look like a utility closet. I am, I'm in the closet. Yeah, yeah.
Okay. Pause. Anybody? Anybody? Hang on. Oh, let me just do it in advance. Does anyone ground ball guys? Just to bank it.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da. I came out of there years ago. Okay, there we go. Okay. So, but, but I went through. Have you ever seen Vaughnville? Cause Sean would love to walk you through some of the, every time on the set of Will and Grace,
they all did that to each other. Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da. I read somewhere once that you were like, it's massive OCD clean freak. Cause I am a little bit of that too. I am. Yeah. Yeah, I've got a problem.
Yeah, I'm not. You do? What's it like for, what's happening for you? Like, did you have a messy childhood, Jenny or something? Sorry, Jay. Yeah, I did. I did have a messy childhood. Wait, Jenny, don't drop your voice
and get real real with us. I did. Oh, boy. I did have a messy childhood. I think that's why I did. Adjusting in my, in my jeans. I did, I did have a messy childhood. I did, I did.
I had a messy childhood and, but very clean grandmothers like tidy houses and there was just like a big obvious like, oh, I'm way less stressed out at both of my Nana's houses than in our house where it's like crazy. It's like crazy. Yeah, I'm the same way. I grew up like in a mess.
So then your OCD comes from trying to create order and cleanliness as opposed to trying to avoid germs. Yeah, I don't think I have. I mean, obviously I'm kind of like at the COVID level of afraid of germs that maybe most people are, but for me, a tidiness means like, untidiness means like an unsettled mind. And it like makes me feel crazy.
And there are like little things that, like I don't understand why you would ever leave anything open. Like why you would leave the cabinet open. I can't get that. A dishwasher, a jar, that's crazy to me. What about toothpaste tube? What about toothpaste? For me, it's more on with you
on the people who can leave a cupboard that much open. I'm like, just close it. I was just, my friend Eli. What else are you leaving open, right? What? Because if you leave those things open, what else are you leaving open? Holy shit, holy shit.
Just come real here, you guys. Hey, wait, Shawn, you're not a, first of all, Jason, the term OCD is way overused. It's not OCD, just to be clear, it's not OCD. So nice try. It's the same way that everybody says that, I don't know, we just use a lot of these terms that are just a little overused.
Sorry, man, I'll work on it. Yeah, okay, thank you. I'm a little intense today, Jenny, because my, my, my work out correct. We interrupt them right in the middle of it. What were you blasting buys and... No, just doing it, just doing a little boxing, bro. Just doing boxing.
Right on, right on. Were you winning or? I hope so, because I was up against a bag. All right, so Eli. But Eli would, he would go, when we were in Atlanta, and I'd come to the kitchen in the morning, and there'd be four glasses, some cups, and whatever stacked next to the sink.
And I'd go, and stuff open, I'd go, at least forget, I get you're not gonna put it in the dishwasher. Can you not put it at least in the sink? It is how much, it's easier. Gravity would take your hand down even further into the sink. And run some water in it.
And run some water in it. And he literally, at one point, just kind of let me go, yeah, I don't know. Wow, yeah. You got a deal on this roommate, huh? Yeah. Yeah, Scotty can't handle when there's actual, like, pieces of food in the sink too.
Like, if I just put a plate down... He has to rinse it out. Yeah, I always, I always clean the food, make sure there's no food in the sink, but I don't really put the dishes in the dishwasher. He likes to do that. He likes to do that. Oh, that's nice.
And now, a word from our sponsor. And now, back to the show. Jenny, I don't know if you're like this. I like things to be orderly and stuff. And at the same time, I'm not like a, I'm not a germaphobe, but I just like things as certain to be kind of clean and sorted.
And sorted. Yeah, I like that too. I like to, like, display my kitchenware like it is sort of a useful art installation. When people, like, move the bowls around, I'm like, okay, but like, I know it's not okay to be un-chill about that, but then when sort of the people are gone,
I'll put it back. But I mostly, I'm just like, yeah, I like to, I think it's about respect. I really do. And I like how it feels to close the circle. Like, when I make dinner every night, and like, while the thing is, was just saying this to a friend, like I guess this is a big thing.
I love a clean station. And when whatever's on the stove, getting, you know, having its final, you know, moment on the stove, I do all the dishes I can. Yeah. I love it. I get that.
It feels so good to me. I get that. You know what, I'm gonna share with you guys a story that I haven't really told you before. Tuck in. Which was, I think I was kind of messy when I was younger. I went to all boys boarding school. And when I was there,
I was in seventh grade, I was 12. And hang on, it gets mildly, mildly interesting. We're gonna start at 12? Okay. And I one day, and the guy who ran the house kept telling me, you gotta clean your room, you gotta clean your room. Finally one day, I came back and my shit was everywhere. And I came back and all my shit was gone from my room.
And I go, where's my stuff? And he goes, come with me. And he'd taken all my stuff and put it in garbage bags and put it in the back of his car. And he drove me six miles away. And I had four garbage bags full of stuff. And I was a little 12, and these big bags of stuff. And he was like, put them down and he said that,
hopefully now you'll learn to clean your room. And he drove away. And so I had these four huge bags and six miles. And I thought, how am I gonna do it? So I started doing like two bags, 50 yards, go back at the other two bags, they were too big. Are you kidding me? No, I swear to God.
And at a certain point I thought like, I'm gonna fucking break, like what's gonna happen here? And I was like, you know what I gotta do? And I just opened, I started putting everything on in jackets and whatever. And I managed to get most stuff on and then just had a small bag left of stuff. Oh my God.
And I walked like a Michelin, true story. And I walked back and I came, I remember crossing the first soccer field towards my house and him seeing me way sooner than he thought he was gonna see me. And I was carrying the shit, but I was wearing everything. And I felt like a fucking king. And I was like, fuck you.
I figured it out, you dummy. And then did you just throw it all over your room again? But you know what, last lap on me, from then on I was much better. I was much better about cleaning my stuff. This was a boarding school? Yeah, this was 1982. Wow.
Wow. I remember when my dad got blasted drunk one night, which was very, very often, he came home. And the dishes weren't done. So he's really furious about that. Did he take an Uber, do you think? They took all the sturdy dishes. And we had linoleum tile on the floor and the kitchen floor.
And he put a dirty dish on every single tile so you couldn't walk on the kitchen floor. Oh, so he was a psycho too. He was a little bit of a psycho, yeah. God darn it. We've really gotta find him. For a very special Christmas episode of Smart List, that's gonna be mine.
This is a recurring theme, Jenny, just so you know. By the way, and also, sorry, Jenny, we'll get back to you in just two seconds. Oh, no. Oh, I gotta get you. Take it. Is that my dad? Jenny, could you bring the fucking bounty up to the front?
We need more fucking bounty. Got the phone, Jenny, God damn it. Jenny, get the phone. Jenny, where the fucking trash bags? Answer it, answer it. Let's see what it is. If it's an order for some milk or something. Somebody answered it.
The machine got it. Somebody answered it. I guess it. What if you answered the phone, the person said, you get off this fucking podcast right now. You shit, you got that computer, and you get off the fucking podcast with your Hollywood friends.
Yeah. So wait, Jenny, I wanna ask you, you've done a million voiceovers, like, and you're regular on Big Mouth and Bob's Burgers, right? Yeah, and the Great North, it's on Fox. And the Great North on Fox. I mean, it's so, why voices? Like, when did you learn like you could do
all of these different things with your voice? I honestly feel like I didn't know that, I didn't know this could be like an actual job that you can do a lot. And I don't know if you guys feel this way, but like, I think it is the most fun. It's so, it's like, it's challenging creatively, but it's really also really easy.
Not that I'm showing up in my PJs, but like, do you hear these ladies behind the door? It's good, it's good, it's good out, mom. No, we haven't asked, are you in the supply, are you in the supply room of the general store? Yeah, between the groceries and the books. No, are you really in the supply? Is that true?
Yeah. Oh wow. And right now it's, so it's 1.31 there. So you've got the lunch rush. So is Ben slapping together a bunch of pastrami? Sandwiches and, you know, who's number 35? Yeah. So he owns the store, but he doesn't like work here every day.
He just, he and his brother. So he has like great grandmother used to come to this store. His family has lived in this town for a really long time. And during the pandemic, he and his brother bought the store and like did a little work on it and they put a bar in here in a bookstore. And so he's kind of like, he's like the store owner. And then he comes here every day
to do like little things for the store. But there's a lovely woman named Mary Ann, who is the manager. And she is letting me be in her office. Can you still do all your voiceover work given the wifi limitations out there? I can, but sometimes it's really bad. Like I do it in the linen closet
between my bedroom and my daughter's bedroom. And I have a little baby. Yeah, she's 17 months old. Oh, congrats. Oh my God. I thought of it, that's so amazing. First of all, I thought of the name for your autobiography if you ever want one. Here we go, here we go.
Sure, let's go. Closets, because you have a lot of closets in your life. You've got to get the slide fluid out, Sean. Or just my life in closets, you know? That's really clever. Yeah, thank you. So who was the tougher transition from you from living single and having all your stuff
in an orderly way? Was it harder for you to get used to living with Ben or the 17 month old? What's been the bigger transition? Great question. That's a really good question. Take your time. It does come down to the neat freak thing.
I think it was harder with the baby, because also like Ben, you know, understands what I say. And so when I'm like, I don't like when that's like that, he doesn't just like be like, you know, like he can understand a threat when he hears one. Right, that's right. Yeah, whereas the baby just doesn't understand my threats yet.
Isn't that amazing how you cannot negotiate with something that doesn't speak your language? Like that was a big, big lesson for me. Like I can't just say, well, you're not having, you know, dessert tonight or whatever, like they don't care. You got for the first couple of years, you got to just deal with it.
Yeah. So Jason, you'd, how, what was the age that your kids finally were able to understand? I'm going golfing today. Like what was the, because for a while they just, you know what I mean? Yeah, that was, they were 12. But wait, so, so Jenny, so you have a 17 month old daughter.
Yeah. And you guys, and now you're firmly living back in Massachusetts and Ben and his brother have opened the general store and you're there and you've kind of, you're, are you done with the West Coast? Are you done with LA? Are you done with New York? Are you just like, I'm gonna, this is where,
for now in your mind, are you like, this is my life now living here? I like it here more, but we still have my house in LA on the east side, you know. On the east side. Is that what you said? Here's the thing, on the east side, on the east side in silver.
By the way, that's a Massachusetts thing to say, by the way, which is like, oh, must be nice. You know? Must be nice. Must be nice. What does Ben think about, what does Ben think about Los Angeles? He likes it a lot.
He, I mean, we had two years there before the baby was born and he was like, whoa, I can't believe you just picking like an orange off the tree and you go for hikes and it's like very chill. I mean, we don't have like a, I don't know, like a super flashy lifestyle. So I think he was like, this is vacation-y, like this is pretty vacation-y or rich it is.
And my best friends live all around us and everything, but I will say about our house in LA, like it's a beautiful, small, old house. I bought it when I was single and I was like a heavy stoner and like the refrigerator is not even in the kitchen. It's in like a tiny room off the kitchen. And at the time I was like, I was single and I was like, it's like under the Tuscan sun,
like I'm just gonna buy an old house and just live in here and have all my shirts. And like, this will be very romantic for me. And then he came, you know what I mean? Like just like, oh, my blouses. Like it's just me and my blouses and I just don't give a hoot anymore about anything. I'm just living in my old home.
And then Ben came to live with me and I was like, oh my God, it's so messy in here, all like with two people even. It's crazy. And Ben's like, where are all these shirts? And he's like, what? He never told me that he had so many blouses. We need to open a general store, yeah.
Right, totally. Just drove him to that. So anyway, so I was like, oh, I love this house. Then he came and I was like, ooh, there's kind of a lot of stuff in here now with two people. And, but I felt like it was fine. And then now with the baby
and also we got a dog during the pandemic, like a beautiful large border collie mix. That house is like, it's just really hard. It's way too small and the stairs are really loud. And... You okay, Will? Yeah, I'm fine. Take a minute, man.
Sorry, I know, throw it in your mouth at the time. Clean the microphone a little bit, I guess. I'm sorry. Jesus Christ. I'm doing my favorite, favorite, truly. I'll never have a better joke than burping. I mean, I'm sorry about that. Sorry about that, you guys.
Welcome to Barstil Sports. I know I'm done. So... So, but you guys have decided we're going to, what is your child's name? Her name is Ida, I-D-A. So you guys said let's,
we're going to raise Ida in Massachusetts. Not out here in L.A., let's, yeah. Good choice. I think so. Tell me what's happened to her. They were like, where do you want to live? And she said, I don't know. Or Ida, huh? Oh, you've got it.
Thanks. What happened to your weed addiction? Did you crack that while you were pregnant? You got rid of all that? Or are we back into... No, no, no, no, no. She doubled down when she was pregnant. What the fuck do you think?
Yeah, I went straight to meth. Yeah, I'd like to go wide with that. I'd like to go wide with that on a podcast about how I've doubled down. Nine months till the baby's here, I got to just do all the drugs. No, I... Is it legal in Massachusetts
like it is out here in California? I think it is. I think it is now. I think it is. I actually, I had like a bad moment of like, I don't know if it's possible, but I kind of think I overdosed myself on weed. You know, I've done that.
It was not with a joint or anything. Like I used to smoke a lot of weed and I could smoke as much as possible, I guess it seemed like, but I took a CBD gummy that my friend was like, oh, you need to activate it with a THC dropper. And she was like, but you...
And it was like, cause I had like a back issue. I don't think CBD is really real, but that might be controversial either way. She was like, if you want it to work, you have to use the... Gotta kick it in. Yeah, the THC dropper. And she was like, but you smoke so much weed
that, you know, it says between one and three droppers, you should probably take three droppers. So I was like, cool, I'll take three droppers. And then... You had to call your mom. I took the three droppers. And I just, I mean, it was like, I think it was like the worst experience of my life
during which I tried to watch the movie, Omelie and couldn't figure out what language it was in. And was just like, what is this? That movie's so good. Oh man, yeah. I'm trying to work it in to stand up now, but it's still like a little scary that this happened. You know, it's like, it's not exactly funny yet
because I actually think I did almost die. And I threw up like outside of my bathroom because I like couldn't figure out how to get over the threshold. Like just crazy shit. Went to bed with all my clothes on, my boots, like some like little zipper up booties, like got in the bed that way.
Text, I need to call for help, need to call for help. And then was like, it's too late Jenny, it's too late. And then I looked, it was 6.45 PM. And I was like, oh, it was just, it was so bad. And this is truly like, oh my God, I really was like watching Amélie being like, when did this movie get so fucking scary? And what language is this?
What is this? Like, I don't know. I used to love this and her hairstyle was so great and everything just looked crazy. But anyway, so then the next day, my friend, you know, it was Jane Levy. Do you know her? You must know.
Yeah, so she gave me the THC thing. Anyway, so she called me and she was like, I got all your texts about the patriarchy. Uh-oh. And I was like, uh-huh. And she was like, I, Jenny, I'm so sorry. It wasn't one, not one to three droppers. It was, I misspoke, it was one to three drops.
And so I took like 120 times the dose. Yeah, and I like ruined my mind. And then, and I was like, I guess I'm off weed. And like a couple of months later, I thought I'll just take a little hit and try and get back in. And it was like, it went right back to where I had been that evening, so I'm just done forever.
Yeah, I'm not gonna try it. Oh my God, so she saved you. She saved you. Yeah, in a way, she saved me. Yeah. Wow, that's so crazy. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show.
Jenny's speaking of like getting freaked out and stuff. You know, your Netflix special called Stage Fright, you know, it was so fucking great. I loved it so much. You talk, I love the way it was shot, by the way. It's so cool. But anyway, you talk about like fear and how you hate it and you love it
and you motivates you and how people say, just be yourself. And you were like, that's the worst advice because there's a million people in my head. Yeah. How do you choose the right pick? So how do you talk about like the love and the hate of performing live? Like what is it you, what freaks you out about it?
I like it so much, but it must be like what like adrenaline junkies are like, I guess, I mean, I don't know. But not the guy that does the free solo. I actually think that, I sound like an old woman, but that really makes me angry that he does that. There's another one. There's another one that makes him look like. There's one that he talks about the other guy.
The Alpinist. The Canadian kid. Wait, what? Isn't it called The Alpinist? And that one's really sad. The Alpinist. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. But man, oh man, what a documentary.
Most of them don't end with like, don't have amazing endings, you know what I mean? No, they're not like a lot of times back in the parking lot at the end. No, oh, you mean the guy who climbs the ice waterfall at night by himself with no ropes? Does it end well? Yeah, all the guy with the bears,
the guy who did all those cute movies of the bears. That's what I still need to say. Oh yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Also, I got busted on not seeing the Revenant the other night by at dinner with my parents and my husband because I said that a snuggie was like that guy in the Revenant who wears a bear suit.
And everyone was like, yeah, like, truly everything. Everyone was like, what are you talking about? You're talking about Leonardo DiCaprio, like the Oscar winner, the actor, the guy. That, he's not the guy, he's Leonardo DiCaprio. And he doesn't wear a bear suit. Like, I guess he gets attacked. I didn't see it, I was too afraid.
It's stunning. You should just see that once. Or just watch the YouTube special on how they shot that scene. Yeah, it's amazing. That seems like out of safe distance. Oh my God. There's also a YouTube video about the guys
getting prepared to shoot the YouTube video for the, which is amazing. That seems like a safe and up-to-date. It's mainly just in the parking lot and putting on Patagonia's and shit, but it's good. No, I need to be pretty far afield, I think, of the central experience. I don't really want it.
Wait, go back to the fear thing. Oh, well, yeah, I think the fear is that people don't like that they won't like me and that they won't think of, like, yeah, that I'll be wearing a Patagonia jacket and I'll be like. They're great jackets. They're great jackets. They're expensive.
Well, they're expensive, but if you're a size large, they're great. They're great. Sorry, I just had to put that out there. They're telling just what you need to tell, yeah. So what, so that fear of, when you're up there on stage and they're not gonna like you, if you play that out in your head,
is it like that, oh my God, I have no place to go? I can't, I can't hide. Right, because you still do it. Yeah, I mean, it feels like a social thing. I like it, that I'm gonna have to be up here and they're all gonna see me like just like choking and floundering and being out of control and all the things that if I succeed at,
they'll see me as a master of like, you know, the moment and like chaos and power or whatever. Not that I see it that, but I think that would be the other side of it. Not that I think I'm like the master of chaos and I'm on stage. I would imagine that you'd have to find a place of like the perfect combination
between sort of an adversarial relationship with the audience, right? So that you feel sort of puffed up and strong, like a worthy adversary and you can defend yourself, but then also kind of be a teammate with the audience too. You wanna try to find that connection with them. I bet that's a really, that's a real challenging place for stand-ups.
I don't think I'd ever have the spine to do it. But it's like a date. Terrifying. I think of it like a date. Like you're like, the person could do things. I actually think you don't have the balls to do it. Fine. Or the spine.
Or the spine. No skeletal structure whatsoever. Or sac. I don't think you have the sac. I don't think you have any of the undercarriage to do it. Sorry, Jamie. So I don't have that undercarriage either. No, you do.
And I am so high. You do. You do it. And it's just terrible. How often are you still getting up there and doing stand-up? Well, in LA, I was, so I usually go up at Largo
and I was trying to go like twice a week while I was there because I want to make a new special. And that's harder, obviously, like when I want to put the baby to bed and, you know, and I like it when Ben sees my sets because especially after having the baby, it's like, oh, I guess I'm just this person who like complains about like almost everything all the time.
I really want him to see me as someone who other people think is like literally in the cheapest way, like popular. Like I would like him to, you know, like everything's fine, but I'm just like, that's such a good friend. I think it's such a good look, you know, up there on stage, if they're liking you, it's like, oh, right. I forgot that there's this powerful person
and it is nice, but it's also really scary. And, but I have to do it. Do you make him the butt of any jokes? Either intentionally or unintentionally. Like when you're sharing your stuff about home and the kid and adjusting to that new life in your house, like did you back in to sort of throwing him under the bus at all?
I used to do that on talk shows with my wife and then she straightened me out. Did you ask permission or would you just like? I didn't. And then I got my snout smacked and then I started asking for permission and then she started saying no. And then I started looking for different material.
Sure, sure, sure. Jenny, I want to talk about, I want to leave you with Marcel the Shell because it's so good. I watched the movie last night. It's so good. Here's what I need to say. I've been a fan of Marcel the Shell, The Shoes On, forever.
I know it's been like over 10 years or something like that. Right? Yeah, yeah. And I used to watch this videos all the time. And what I love about it is if you haven't seen it, all you need to know about it is in the title. It's literally Marcel the Shell and he has shoes on. And you literally play a shell named Marcel
and he, how the voice, like how the voice, why the voice? Are you sick of the voice? Tell us all things about Marcel because how did you think of him and are you kind of like done or more, more and more because I can't get enough of him. Oh, thanks, thanks, thanks for saying that. Like right, sidebar really quick. I loved when Marcel played taps from his horn,
which was a piece of hollow spiral macaroni. And he sleeps in his bread room, which is a bedroom made out of bread, which is fantastic. Well, bless him. And when he played taps, he plays taps. That is, that's like my favorite part of the, that like sort of, it's a sad part. It's a sort of like a eulogy part.
And it's so funny. And it's also terribly sad. It's a macaroni. Yeah, it's like a shofar. In my culture, we call that a shofar. Yeah, for sure. There's a lot of secret Judaism put in there. I'm not sick of the voice.
I love doing it. It's like, it feels like a, you know, like, I don't know, like a soothing thing. I do it by myself a lot. I like it. It came up one weekend when I was like in a hotel room, sharing a hotel room with like five friends and everyone was like broke.
And we were all sharing a hotel room. And like every thing you could sleep on was being used. Like the cot and the two beds and like someone on the floor, whatever, and they were just like all men. And I felt like tiny and that it was like so messy and cramped in there. And I started to talk to like sort of rib people in that voice.
And then, and then my partner at the time had like promised that he was going to make a video for a little show in Williamsburg and he hadn't done anything yet. And he was like, could I interview that voice? And like maybe there will be a character and I'll, you know, make something with it. So he interviewed me in that voice and then he made Marcel's body.
And we just like made that video. It's so cool. So is he still a part of all the stuff going forward? Yeah, Dean Fleischer Camp. He's the director and we co-wrote it together with our friend Nick Paley. And yeah, yeah, he's, he did everything. I love, there's a million one-liners,
but you know what Marcel uses for his skis? Our men's toenails. Yeah, toenails come in hand. Tonal clippings, not the actual toenail. Full toenail. Yeah, yeah, just the clippings. Did I see a trailer for it that's coming up? Yes.
Yeah, it's coming out June 24th through 824. What? And you filmed it like over a year ago, right? It took seven years to make. Wow. Jesus. Yeah, we finished it. I want to say in the winter of- You wanted it to take seven years.
Well, cause it stopped motion and we weren't, you know, we were like fully funded by Cineridge. It's like a, it's not a studio. It's like basically like getting arts grants basically and which also gave us total. Freedom. Yeah, which is really great. And it took a long time, the film was improvised
off of a long treatment. So we would like record, like improvise, and then Dean and Nick would go back and cull through all the audio and start to make a script off of that. And then like write things that we should say and go back into more improvising. And that process itself took about a couple years. And then you would do the stop motion.
Yeah, then I think the order was we locked like the audio play, like everything that Marcel and his grandmother is the only other character besides Dean played, grandmother played by Isabella Rossellini, who is incredible. Nice. And she has a beautiful voice. Yeah.
And so we did, and she let us go to her farm to improvise. Like when there were scenes- Where's the farm? It's in New York. Yeah. City? Yeah, it's in this city. It's so weird cause I'm 56th street.
It's so high. Yeah, so strange. It's just a farm and then what are they? They just raise improvisers? That's amazing. Yeah, it's called Yes and Farm. Oh my God, that's amazing. Yeah, I just love that.
I love that about her. Anyway, yeah, so we recorded it all and then they filmed the live action cause like Marcel is, you know, like he's in a physical house and obviously Dean is the real person that you sometimes see like his hand or him walking away. They filmed all the live action, the whole movie's worth and then they filmed the stop motion animation on that.
It's so good, I love it. I loved it so much. It's, please go see it if you haven't seen it. June 24th. June 24th. June 24th, yeah. This is my sister's birthday. Is that right?
Happy birthday. Well, two of them cause they're twins. Oh, that's both of them then. What are both their names, well, quick. Tannis and Shanley. Good, and what about your brother? Chuck. Wow.
Wait, why do we test me on this all the time? I know. Jenny, it's such a pleasure. Thank you for being here. I want everybody to go to the movie. Jenny. You're hilarious and a delight. Yeah, I really am.
Gentlemen, so are you. You really are. This is really, really fun. Next time you're out in Silver Lake, come by the smart Lestudios. That'll be nice. They don't exist. Oh, they don't.
You don't have to. We're building a whole compound out there to rival, she's about to rustle in, he's a yes and ranch. Yep, yes and ranch, top of the rock. You can't miss it if you're running out of there. Top of the rock, top of the rock. She's just up there hoeing. Anyway, honey, thank you.
We love you. I'm so proud of you and I'm excited for the movie. I hope it does really well. Thank you so much. Thank you, Jenny. Please say hi to Ben and Ida. Tell her I miss her. I will.
Bye, Jenny. Bye, bye, bye, Jenny. Bye. You just slam. I go now, right? Yeah, you go now. You go. I go now.
Goodbye, thank you. You go now. Bye. That's Jenny Slate, y'all. Yeah, I love her. She is great. She's a killer. She's a real killer.
I know, everybody knows her voices, right? But they don't know that she probably does all of them because they're all so different. I did a small movie with her. She was on camera, not just the voice, the face, the whole acting, the whole thing. What was the movie? She's very, very good.
I believe it's called The Longest Week. It wasn't a large film, but she was in it and she was great. I really had a good time with her. She's real fun. She's super fun, cute, funny, just adorable, super talented. Oh my God, great energy, great fun. She should teach improv and voiceover stuff because she's...
I know, it was pretty good. Well, Will, sir, are you gonna go back, work out and finish that now? No, I was just finishing up and I'm really rattled. I'm now so hungry, obviously. Well, go get something to eat. And then I gotta go meet Jason.
We got a meeting. Yeah, we got a lunch meeting. Hey, so what are you gonna eat prior to your one o'clock lunch? I am fucking... What's it gonna be, though? Is it gonna be a protein shift? Are you gonna ruin all the work you've done this morning?
Punch in that dumb white bag. There it is. My energy has really plummeted in the last 10 minutes. That's sugar. Yeah, no, I sugar. All right, well, why don't we let you go? Yeah, go right now. I think you're coming today.
We're huge fans. No, oh, wait, wait, wait, and do I just slam shut? Yeah, you just slam shut. Listen, and if you're feeling... I want you to eat. I want you to just go grab something that looks like it's got a lot of carbohydrates in it and just take a big bye.
Bye. Bye. I'm in, I'm in, I'm in. Smart, lost. Smart, lost. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbaco. Smart, lost.
Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.